hi erin i heard you set up continuous
integration for your cloud app uh why
did you do that
well integrating new code can be a
painful process say if a build breaks or
new code causes a unit test to fail so
the thought is to do it often and
automatically to minimize that that's
all ci or continuous integration is
right that's what i've read in the dora
research report as well
could you show me how it works i'd be
happy to
[Music]
all right how can i try out your
continuous integration well my
application lets the user take notes and
store them in the cloud you told me
before that you've used it is there
anything you'd like to change yeah the
app lets me save an empty note that's a
little confusing i'd like to prevent
that
sounds good
clone the source code to your machine
open it in your editor and implement
your change
all right
doing so now
and aaron i have to admit i cheated and
peaked at the code ahead of time i think
the code should check for the length of
the note here
not save the note if the length is zero
characters
all right that sounds reasonable
now in order to get this change into the
main branch we'll push it to a feature
branch then create a pull request on
github
all right
doing so now
[Music]
and done
i'll just take a minute to review your
commit
by the way i'm using github but you can
set up ci with bitbucket gitlab and most
other repo providers you can even do it
on a local build server in your office
there's your pull request
my continuation integration process will
now build and test it
looks like it failed let's see
everything compiled but a unit test
failed
uh oh uh how to fix that
this is actually what we want if there
is a bug in a commit the process should
stop us from merging into the main
branch
we can just fix the failing test commit
and push to get moving again
okay uh looks like it threw a null
pointer exception here when the note is
null instead of an empty string
i think this here will fix it
okay
i'll then run the tests uh to make sure
that my fix is all right
looks like it passed the tests okay uh
now what aaron
now all we need to do is push the fix to
that same branch and the build should
pass okay doing so now
there
all done all right let me check out your
pull request again
looks like the building test worked well
done
yeah i probably should have run the unit
test before i submitted my code the
first time huh
we live and learn everything passed so i
will now merge your code into the main
branch
this continuous integration process
looks useful it prevented my bad code
from being merged into your
application's main branch
now how can i set that up in my code
repo aaron
we can walk through that no problem
all we'll need to get started is a
target repo and a build configuration
file okay i've got my repo here uh but
not a build config file yet
that's fine we can start by enabling the
cloud build api
then as a starting point i can send you
a quick cloud build.yaml that just runs
our unit tests
great uh i received the cloudbuild.yaml
file
it looks like it's running the unit
tests here on these lines
but how do i trigger the build
automatically
for that we'll need to set up a cloud
build trigger
to do that we can go over to the
triggers page in the cloud console
select your project and click open
click connect repository
then we'll need to sign in and install
the cloud build github app which does
the actual work of building and
deploying your app
after that we're able to pick a
repository and make a trigger
okay uh what kinds of triggers can i
make uh can i pick which branches should
trigger a build yeah absolutely you can
specify the name of a branch or even use
full regex matches
very cool
what if i want to make sure my whole
cloud run service works not just
individual unit tests
you're right while your unit tests
ensure that a part of your project works
well on its own
we can use integration tests to make
sure that one or more of these parts
work well together
ah interesting uh so i've got my unit
tests here already uh how would i set up
an integration test of my whole cloud
run service
now that depends sometimes the parts
that you're testing against are small
and lend themselves well to being mocked
up for a test
other times the parts are so large that
it's more manageable to test against a
live service
i can think of a few situations where
i'd want to set up an integration test
against a live service like you said uh
do you have any docs on how to set that
up
yep absolutely we have microservice
sample repos with a test cloud
build.yaml that deploys a cloud run
service runs some integration tests by
making http calls to that deployed
service and then tears it all down i'll
send you the link to the java one but we
also have python node and go versions
that sounds perfect i'll take a look
thanks again aaron anytime aaron and
thank you everyone for watching if you
have questions for aaron or me please
add them in the comments also let us
know in the comments if there are other
serverless topics you'd like to hear
about in future episodes
see you next time
[Music]
you